Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Io, come mi ha introdotto,
adoro viaggiare.
Voi, immagino,
la maggior parte di voi almeno,
credo che in qualche modo
siate appassionati,no, dei viaggi.
Quindi ho avuto la fortuna, così,
di coadiuvare un pochino,
grazie al lavoro che faccio
e all'esperienza che ho nel mio business,
di organizzare un viaggio
che ha avuto come tema di fondo
la sostenibilità,
quindi la mobilità alternativa
e la nutrizione anche,
da un punto di vista sostenibile.
Quindi ho organizzato un viaggio
che è durato due mesi,
adesso andremo a vedere,
nei prossimi minuti
che cosa è stato questo viaggio.
Alla fine, forse,
la mia idea piano piano
è cresciuta sempre di più,
perché ho messo insieme questi temi,
è diventato anche un record mondiale;
ha parlato di ecologia,
di mobilità sostenibile,
di leadership,
perché si è creato un gruppo,
siamo partiti in otto,
la squadra era fatta di otto persone;
era poi un sogno che ho realizzato, quindi
sono tanti i temi che potrei toccare
per raccontarvi questo viaggio.
Però alla fine, oggi,
ho deciso di cercare di focalizzarmi
su un aspetto fondamentale,
che tra l'altro mi sta diventando
molto utile,
nel senso che
da quando sono tornato da questo viaggio
mi sta facendo fare meglio
nella vita quotidiana: è la passione,
che a dire la verità ultimamente avevo
un po' perso nel quotidiano,
nel mio lavoro di tutti i giorni e
inseguendo questo sogno, questo progetto,
ho ritrovato, ecco, la necessità
di dover tenere quotidianamente,
avere sempre a mente
quelle che sono le nostre passioni,
cercare di coltivarle,
non metterle nel cassetto.
Allora qual è stata l'idea.
Io personalmente abito a Shangai
da qualche anno,
dove, appunto, avendo iniziato
una nuova attività lavorativa
non ho avuto il tempo
di coltivare le mie passioni,
quindi dopo qualche anno
di repressione delle passioni
ho deciso di prendermi due mesi sabbatici
e dire tornerò a Milano in moto,
ma non semplicemente in moto,
ho deciso di tornarci
con una moto elettrica.
Allora ho preso un filo
lungo dodicimila chilometri...
no, non è andata così.
Ecco, questo è il progetto,
che adesso andremo a vedere un po'
come si è costruito.
Ho preparato una breve clip.
[Filmato]
Ecco,
questi sessanta secondi ci hanno dato,
così, un brevissimo touch
di quello che è stato il progetto.
Un'idea che è nata una sera,
ho deciso di fare questo viaggio
e all'inizio pensavo
di fare una cosa in autonomia,
però poi, pensando, pensando,
ragionando intorno a questo progetto,
ho cercato di ingrandire un po' lo scopo,
di cercare di coinvolgere anche il tema
non solo della mobilità alternativa,
per cercare di capire se effettivamente
i mezzi del futuro possono essere
a trazione elettrica o ibridi ecc.
ho deciso anche di misurare,
di sperimentare durante il viaggio,
cercare di valutare e studiare
le varie culture alimentari
delle undici nazioni
che abbiamo attraversato.
Quindi con l'Università di Bari,
che è un centro di eccellenza
in quella che si chiama l'LCA,
Life Cycle Assesstment,
cioè la misurazione
dell'impatto ambientale
di un prodotto agroalimentare
dalla sua origine nell'agricoltura
fino alla forchetta, fin dove arriva.
Quindi abbiamo messo insieme questi temi,
è piaciuto moltissimo
il progetto ad Expo Milano,
che ha proprio come tema
la nutrizione, la sostenibilità,
quindi ci hanno supportato
e da lì siamo partiti,
ho messo insieme una squadra.
Questo progetto lo portavo avanti
nei ritagli di tempo,
quindi tantissime notti insonni,
perché ho iniziato ad organizzarlo
sei mesi prima della partenza:
siamo partiti a giugno
e siamo arrivati a Milano a fine luglio,
quindi ci ho messo circa sei mesi
per organizzare questo progetto.
é stato un lavoro veramente faticoso,
la preparazione è stata forse
l'aspetto più difficile,
anche perché partendo dalla Cina
ci sono tantissimi aspetti burocratici
che sono molto complessi.
Siamo partiti finalmente,
lo sforzo, anche in viaggio,
è stato notevole,
perché si stava mediamente
in viaggio otto - nove ore al giorno
in sella alle nostre moto
ed è stata un'esperienza magnifica,
magnifica, piena di problemi,
tantissimi problemi, grandi
anche difficoltà legate alla squadra,
alla squadra che ho reclutato
grazie ad internet.
Io mi trovavo in Cina,
ho creato questo sito web,
ho scritto chi cercavo e chi
volesse condividere l'avventura con me.
Non vi dico quante persone hanno fatto
questa applicazione,
quindi, alla fine ho scelto questo team,
che era composto da un fotografo,
da un meccanico, da un blogger,
da un operatore video,
insomma, era abbastanza consistente,
però non ci conoscevamo.
Immaginatevi partiti alla volta
di un viaggio così epico,
di fatto non ci eravamo mai incontrati,
quindi uno degli aspetti molto difficili,
cerco di toccare quegli aggettivi
che ho usato all'inizio,
il discorso di leadership.
Avendo io organizzato questo viaggio
dovevo in qualche modo
gestire questa squadra,
che di fronte a queste difficoltà...
anche perché siamo stati in paesi
piuttosto difficili,
la Mongolia, in primis,
è assolutamente un paese
che richiede una certa organizzazione
per attraversare quel territorio,
che è un territorio
dove non ci sono strade,
quindi difficile.
In più noi avevamo dei mezzi
che erano di fatto non tradizionali,
avevamo queste motociclette elettriche,
quindi c'è stata
tanta tensione nella squadra.
Queste sono alcune immagini
che fanno capire un po' la fatica
e quanti problemi avevamo
quotidianamente da affrontare,
tecnicamente, di orientamento, ma anche
di gestione, appunto, della relazione,
perché stando sempre insieme,
24 ore al giorno,
le dinamiche proprio di relazione
sono molto complicate,
ci sono stati degli aspetti,
dei momenti molto critici.
Ma la cosa bella,
la cosa molto interessante
- questa è un po' una foto che invece
fa vedere un momento più sereno -
quanto più siamo entrati nella parte
più difficile e tosta di questo viaggio,
che era proprio il deserto mongolo,
dove c'erano anche condizioni
molto difficili, 45°C di temperatura,
insomma, magicamente tutto ha iniziato
a funzionare meglio,
un po' come se la paura e il rischio
di dover sopravvivere,
perché comunque è chiaro
che in quel contesto
viene fuori l'istinto di sopravvivenza.
Magicamente le dinamiche della squadra,
come un ingranaggio,
hanno iniziato a funzionare
alla perfezione.
Questo è stato un grandissimo insegnamento
che mi è servito,
che mi sono portato a casa
e che mi ha fatto sicuramente crescere,
oltre poi alla disponibilità.
Noi abbiamo trovato per la strada
anche famiglie poverissime,
perché in Mongolia ci sono questi nomadi
che vivono giusto
degli animali che allevano,
quindi non hanno quasi nulla,
però sono sempre stati
molto molto ospitali con noi.
Poi c'era l'aspetto della nutrizione.
In questi 44 giorni non abbiamo mai
mangiato qualcosa che non fosse locale,
un cibo locale, quindi abbiamo avuto
un'esperienza alimentare un po' estrema,
quasi tutti hanno avuto
dei problemi anche di stomaco,
però in questo modo ci ha permesso
di documentare,
abbiamo fatto tutta
una documentazione fotografica
che verrà poi utilizzata
all'Expo di Milano,
per raccontare le culture attraverso
quella che è un po' la nutrizione
e quelle che sono le abitudini alimentari.
Di ognuno di questi pasti
che abbiamo fatto in questi 44 giorni
abbiamo poi analizzato quello
che fosse l'impatto ambientale,
cioè quali sono le diete
che sono buone per noi
ma buone anche per il pianeta.
E sono venuti fuori
dei dati molto molto interessanti;
una ricerca, come dicevo,
che abbiamo sviluppato insieme
all'Università di Bari,
quindi con una valenza anche scientifica,
stiamo elaborando adesso questa massa
di dati che abbiamo portato a casa
e anche questo verrà poi sfruttato
durante l'Expo,
ormai fra un anno praticamente.
Quindi potete vedere che
ci siamo dovuti adattare
a mangiare quello che trovavamo
assolutamente sulla strada,
buono o cattivo
o comunque in certi casi,
soprattutto in Cina,
abbiamo avuto anche delle cose che
non sono poi così facili da mandare giù.
Però un'esperienza grandiosa,
un'esperienza che sicuramente
non è così facile da ripetere,
perché ovviamente viaggiare,
un viaggio con un'estensione di tempo
così lunga, non è facile da organizzare
e devi avere quello
che è un bene preziosissimo che è il tempo
e io sono stato molto fortunato di potermi
gestire il mio tempo
da potermi prendere questi due mesi
e coronare così questo sogno.
Però io già sto pensando al prossimo,
ecco: fatta la prima viene già in mente
cos'altro si possa fare.
Di difficoltà, poi,
ne abbiamo avute diverse,
anche da un punto di vista tecnologico.
Appunto, adesso brevemente vi accenno
che tipo di mezzi abbiamo usato.
Come ho detto erano delle moto elettriche,
avete visto nelle foto
che c'erano anche delle automobili che
trasportavano il resto dell'equipaggio,
quindi una delle prime domande
che tutti fanno è
perché avete usato delle moto elettriche
e poi delle auto al seguito
che bruciavano benzina.
Beh, è verissimo, però appunto,
ho cercato un cavo
lungo dodicimila chilometri
ma non l'ho trovato,
quindi ho deciso di portare
delle auto dietro
che potessero aiutarci a trasportare
l'energia necessaria per alimentare
queste motociclette elettriche,
che veniva prodotta da dei pannelli solari
installati su queste macchine
e poi anche dalla rete,
quindi ci siamo alimentati,
dove era possibile, anche dalla rete.
Comunque sia il viaggio è stato poi
analizzato e misurato
dal punto di vista delle emissioni di CO2:
E siamo riusciti a ridurre del--
il nostro impatto di CO2,
rispetto ad un viaggio
con dei veicoli tradizionali
a combustione,
comunque è stato meno della metà:
del 56 percento in meno.
Sicuramente l'obiettivo di fare
un'avventura ecologica lo abbiamo centrato
è chiaro che i vincoli
di queste nuove tecnologie
sono molto legati alla disponibilità
di una rete energetica,
però quello che io volevo provare era
dimostrare che ci sono delle alternative.
La tecnologia, in questo senso,
sta facendo dei passi avanti notevoli
e in qualche modo abbiamo testato
nell'estremo che è possibile muoversi
con dei mezzi che abbattono decisamente
l'impatto ambientale.
Quindi siamo tornati a casa
dopo 44 giorni,
con un ottimo, grandissimo benvenuto
all'Expo di Milano.
È stato un viaggio perfetto,
avevo fatto una tabella di marcia
e siamo arrivati esattamente
il giorno in cui era previsto,
dopo 44 giorni,
quindi l'esperienza
è andata perfettamente,
è stata un successo,
tanto che, appunto, vorrei ripetere
qualcosa di simile in futuro,
mantenendo questi due temi fondamentali,
di un'avventura ecologica che si svolge
attraverso il viaggio
con mezzi, veicoli a zero
o a basso impatto ambientale
e per documentare le abitudini alimentari
dei paesi attraversati.
Ovviamente, dopo aver avuto
le celebrazioni di arrivo,
tutti contenti, tutto bene, al lavoro,
via, tornato in Cina,
però appunto,
questo è un altro aspetto interessante,
perché, come dicevo prima,
non ho perso due mesi di lavoro
credo invece di aver fatto un'esperienza
che mi serve molto anche nel quotidiano,
non solo perché ho qualcos'altro
di nuovo da raccontare,
ma anche perché, appunto,
a livello di esperienza
di team building, di gestione
delle relazioni con queste persone ecc.
ci sono stati tanti elementi
che mi hanno fatto imparare cose nuove,
oltre che aver risvegliato la passione
e che, come dicevo prima,
per qualche anno
avevo dovuto mettere da parte
e devo dire che tornare a lavoro
con questo background di stimoli
mi sta dando una motivazione in più
per dare il meglio anche nel mio business.
Quindi, insomma, non mi resta che,
a questo punto, dirvi buon viaggio
e vi auguro, appunto,
di poter inseguire i vostri sogni
e di coltivare le vostre passioni
che sono la cosa più importante.
(Applausi)